to be a good chess player you need to
have confidence and faith in yourself
that you can win a game or so not pay
sore loser and just be smart a girl that
likes to play chess is open to
possibilities she's motivated has to
want to fight
you may start White's pocket you can't
be wounded squirmy kids you'll have to
actually focus not be scared or afraid
of what's gonna happen if there's one
thing every girl needs to have its
determination and if something goes
wrong they don't give up
I think jess is gonna benefit me later
life because you become more aware chess
is like life to me I came a long way
first I was anxious I didn't really know
how to move the pieces or whatever
I think chess is amazing like it's it
gives you a second chance and my grade
I'm the only girl that plays chess I
only know about like two or three girls
including myself and about life fifty
boys a lot of girls are intimidated
because they're not playing against the
same gender more boys play chess and
girls because the really good
grandmasters were like boys so they may
be like nervous and then they already
feel like they lost it's funny because I
usually play boys but every single time
I get really nervous for some reason I
think girls are very intimidated by the
number of boys I I am sometimes they're
like whispering oh look I'm gonna beat
her but then when I beat them they look
totally crushed and they're like how
could I lose how could I lose to a girl
it would just show me how he didn't
really have much respect for his
opponent to get girls in the chest we
can send a message showing them that
girls are equal Febby the only one I'm
like hey where's all the girls go
and now I'm at this huge girls nationals
to uni sex game is not only for one
gender you know what I mean
there's no whispering that you're gonna
lose because you're a girl because we're
all girls I actually get to play girls I
didn't even know and I get to make new
friends with some other girls in my
school definitely look up to me because
I play something that's unique or
different than what usually girls play
when I win is like wow I got this right
in the bag
you're surrounded by I don't know how
many girls are here but you know that
you're not well or you know that there's
way more than just